el sonido de esta sirena marca las 14 50
hora argentina ahora comienza a sonar el
himno argentino
aquí frente a lo que era la embajada de
israel que hace 30 años sufrió el primer
ataque en su tipo en argentina y en
américa latina' un ataque con bomba que
destruyó el edificio en el que ahora hay
una plaza conmemorativa en ese ataque
murieron 29 personas y hubo más de 200
heridos ocurrió en el año 1992 según
israel el ataque fue perpetrado por el
grupo libanés hezbollah y también por
iran pero la justicia argentina no ha
podido determinar quiénes fueron los
autores aquí de ese atentado de hecho
dos años después en 1994 un nuevo ataque
con bomba esta vez en la asociación
mutual israelita argentina una
organización comunitaria judía en este
país que es el que tiene la mayor
población
de américa latina' como decía una bomba
en la asociación mutual y realista
argentina dejó 85 personas muertas y 300
heridos otra vez un caso que no ha sido
aún resuelto por la justicia argentina y
aquí se pide justicia y memoria 30 años
después del atentado a la embajada de
israel